dividing by 10 a lot like multiplying by
10 creates a pattern with numbers so
let's dig in and look at dividing by 10
look at what happens when we divide by
10 and see if we can figure out that
pattern and maybe even how it relates to
the pattern for multiplying by 10.
let's take a
fairly simple one to start let's say
something like 30
divided by 10.
one way to think about this is we're
taking the number thirty and we're
dividing it into groups of ten
so let's see how many groups of ten it
takes to make thirty
one group of ten is ten so that's not
enough
plus a second group is 20
plus a third group is 30. so 30 can be
thought of as 10 plus 10 plus 10 or
3 groups of 10.
so if we divide 30 by 10 divide 30 into
groups of 10 we end up with
three
groups
let's try another one
maybe something slightly trickier maybe
let's go with a hundred ten
divided
by ten
and again we're dividing we're taking
110 and dividing it into groups of ten
so let's see how many groups of ten it
takes to get to a hundred ten
there's one ten plus another is twenty
thirty
forty
fifty
another ten gets us to 60
80. we're getting closer
and 110
so this right here is how many groups of
it takes us to get to 110
so let's see how many groups is that
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11.
our solution is eleven if we have a
hundred ten and we divide it into groups
of ten
we end up with eleven groups
well let's look at these first two let's
pause here and see if we see a pattern
30 divided by 10 was 3
110 divided by 10 was 11.
so what happened what happened to the 30
and the 110
to get these quotients
and what happened is
the zero the zero on the end was taken
off our solution is the same
but with the zero taken off the end here
again the solution is the same
with a zero taken off the end
and if we remember for multiplication it
was the opposite
if we had 2 times 10 instead of dividing
times 10
our solution
was 20 or a 2 our original number
with a zero added to the end
remembering another one something like
13 times 10
our product our solution is a 13 the
original number with a zero added to the
end
so in multiplication when we multiply by
10 we add a zero to our whole number at
the end
and when we divide when we do the
opposite by 10
we take off a zero from the end of our
whole number
so knowing that pattern let's try one
more maybe one where we don't work out
all the tens but just try to use the
pattern to solve it
if we had something like say seven
thousand
divided by ten
well our solution
is going to be seven thousand
but with a zero taken off of the n
because we're dividing by ten so instead
of seven thousand we would have seven
hundred
seven thousand divided into groups of
ten would be seven hundred groups of ten
so our solution is seven hundred
let's take this all a step further and
let's think about what dividing by ten
is doing to these numbers to thirty to
one ten to 7000 in terms of their place
value
so here's a place value chart let's use
it to look at one of the numbers we
already tried something like 30
and when we divided 30 by 10
remember what happened to the three
instead of being three tens
our solution was three
ones
the three moved one place value to the
right and the 0 really did too it would
move after a decimal
which would be 3.0
which is the same as 3 which is the
reason we didn't need to write that 0
the reason that we could cross it off
so our number instead of being three
tens when we divided by ten became three
ones
let's look at a little bit trickier of
one
we also tried seven thousand so that
would be seven thousands
zero hundred zero tens and zero ones
and when we divided by ten
our seven in our thousands place became
seven hundreds
and the zero hundreds became zero tens
and zero tens became zero ones
and that last zero
we were able to cross off and moved
after the decimal
so 7000 divided by 10 was 700
again everything moved one place value
to the right
so there's two ways to think about
dividing by 10. we could either say you
drop a zero off the end
or we could say that you move every
digit one place value to the right
let's think about it again in terms of
place value with a new number
let's try something like
630.
if we divide 630 by 10
we're going to move everything one place
value to the right so the six hundreds
will become six tens
six ten three tens will become three
ones
and the zero ones
will move after the decimal
so we can say that 630
divided by 10
is equal to sixty
three or six tens and three ones
so again two ways to think about
dividing by ten
either we can cross off a
zero or
we move every digit each digit one place
value to the right